truc à lui c'est qu'on la télé on va
faire une interview qu'on alors notre
village progression à tous les trois
pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut pas aller
voir les poupées russes
je vois pas de bonnes questions
il ya une raison cédric est bien une
raison pour laquelle il faut pas y aller
je suis pas il a du mal à trouver quand
ouais je n'arrive pas à trouver ouais
non pas très alléchant qui aiment pas
oui j'ai pas ça donne envie d'y aller un
météore
qu'est-ce qui est ratée dans ce film à
part la première ratée le style repose
beaucoup sur le rapport entre la voix et
les images voilà au début je sais qu'il
ya trop de choses j'ai dit trop de
choses dans la voix off
il ya des trucs qui me paraissent un peu
redondant dans l'est c'est bien la
première miss n est pas le temps de les
retirer
bah non c'est trop tard alea jacta est
butt chine le plus pourri c'est le cas
elles cécile non chez moi j'ai envie de
dire ah bon non je prend vie dira pas
devant cédric en tout cas vous pourriez
dire de complètement inintéressant sur
hbo voilà
puces
cécile qui détestez vous sur ce plateau
là très peu de gens cédric qu'est ce qui
vous énerve c'est francis cabrel il a
dit une fois
enfin dans une chanson il a dit moi je
reviens du ciel et les étoiles entre
elles ne parlent que de toi voilà ce qui
m'énerve c'est pas de la poésie vivante
qu'est ce que vous aimiez suis raffarin
chez raffarin m'a pas beaucoup de choses
sa démission
vous préféreriez vivre sans moi ou sans
jambes s'il vous plaît pas de service
sont sombres
et oui / non - sans bras le bon nombre
de saints d'après vous c'est combien
bois 2 2 ça va c'est bien pour vous
c'est bien moi ce serait pas mieux non
/ non j'aime bien la vie sur terre mais
si vous étiez qu'on vous seriez qui je
suis con mais c'est vrai aujourd'hui
sinon nous traitez vous aurez quel âge
en 37 ans s'est il senti si non c'est
juste des questions en cours puisque la
télé c'est comme si vous n'étiez pas ici
vous seriez oui ce soir ailleurs
peut-être
at il pas dans un bar
* vous dormez ou ce soir dans un bar la
vintage à oui c'est à côté de chez moi
bien oui qu'est-ce qui pourrait sauver
l'amour
lapierre question est ce que tu viens
pour les vacances je vais bientôt y est
bien vous arrivez à garder les yeux
ouverts quand vous éternuez cécile et
vous savez vous savez si vous gardez les
yeux ouverts
non monsieur que non je me vois